[موسيقى]
تمكنا من ربط
128000 من الشباب والنساء بعالم
العمل
و
58 منهم
من الشابات وما
رأيناه أثناء الطمع هو
أنه عمّق بالفعل أزمة البطالة
بين الشباب والنساء في جميع أنحاء العالم.
منطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا ،
لذا حتى قبل كوفيد ،
كان الشرق الأوسط وشمال
إفريقيا أصعب مكان على هذا الكوكب
بالنسبة للشباب والنساء للحصول على وظيفة
[موسيقى] ،
لقد رأينا تسارعًا في
الاتجاه المغطى مسبقًا نحو المزيد من الوظائف في
التكنولوجيا والرعاية الصحية
تسارع هذا الأمر ، وهو جانب إيجابي ،
فهناك المزيد والمزيد من الوظائف في تلك
القطاعات
التي نحتاج إليها لسد فجوة المهارات ، لذلك يوجد
في المنطقة عدم توافق كبير
بين
ما تقوم به معاهد التدريب المهني
والمدارس الثانوية التي تدرسها الجامعات
للشباب
وما هم أرباب العمل.  تبحث عن
تحدٍ وفرصة أخرى في القطاع الخاص وهو
ريادة الأعمال وتعزيز
ريادة الأعمال ، فأنت تعلم أن خلق فرص العمل
أمر بالغ الأهمية ومنطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا مرة
أخرى غير متكافئة  هناك بعض
الأعمال المهمة حقًا التي يتم إجراؤها في
دول الخليج في النظام البيئي ولكن بشكل عام
المنطقة بها أقل معدل
لرواد الأعمال في العالم وليس
بسبب نقص المواهب بل
بسبب ضعف النظم البيئية